la mode masculine en france cette
fois-ci suite bâtir une collection
dessiné une collection ce n'est pas
simple surtout pour les hommes il faut
pas être si lettres originales mais pas
trop si l'on veut vendre mais alors le
nec plus ultra c'est présenté cela dans
un lieu qui de préférence n'est pas du
tout fait pour a par exemple le métro un
ring de boxe ou bien le grand
amphithéâtre de la sorbonne ce sont les
lieux qui ont choisi jean paul gaultier
et s'est mis à quai et lanvin et que
nous montre michel violet et yoda
grégoire
trouver un lieu original pour fringues
du même nom c'est la devise jean paul
gaultier un ring cette fois ci à ma
droite et à ma gauche aussi look dracula
veste queue de pie pour jambes longues
ensemble normal un petit air de charlie
chaplin pour chapeau plus l'est
jupe kilt je veux dire pantalon en jupe
très jolie les petits-fils et foulards
façon j'adore mais visage découvert pour
moustache taillée autour des narines ou
foulard jean look manifestants pas mal
aussi pour lutter contre la pollution
fantômas à la recherche du fils n'a rien
peut-être accessoires facultatif la
lampe à part selon quoi d'neuf bien il
ya toujours des pantalons des vestes et
des vestons autre lieu autre mode celle
ci de chélan va parfaitement adapté à
l'environnement culturel celui de la
sorbonne retour de la silhouette grand
ailleurs des années 50
couleurs des grilles des bleus
ici et là quelques touches de couleurs
comme celle gillet
les fentes des vestes sont maintenant
sur le côté c'est bien de changer de
temps en temps et pour couronner cette
collection cocorico bleu blanc rouge
c'est l'hommage au bicentenaire métro
porte des lilas 8 heures du matin
chaussées miyake avis les hommes
d'action costumes ou mentaux selon le
temps façon décontractée pour la fin
d'après midi avec opposition de couleurs
les couturiers ont compris les défilés
ce sont des spectacles qu'il faut mettre
en scène le reste est il aussi important
ce qui compte c'est comment le montrer
ils ont beaucoup d'imagination